thanks a lot for the nice interaction
yes my name is Andrea spitting I'm a
physicist and working is a data
scientist at Sur scrum
sis cron is the digitalization effect
company of crohn's and Crohn's though
nobody probably heard of that name
before
is the world leader in the manufacturing
of bottling machines so our clients are
like coke or like all the world lost all
the the whole beverage industry are our
clients and so i want to show you a
little bit like how amazing our machines
are actually so i've like three machines
for you
the first one is the blower so you take
those preforms heat them up to what
about 120 degrees it has to be real like
really exactly and then just to blow in
was about 26 bar for a few milliseconds
to get a perfectly nice formed bottle
it's like a really amazing technique
it's like really crazy thing is like the
high speed filler so we're building
fillers which feel about fifty thousand
bottles an hour
cans go up to 100 thousand cans an hour
that means if you're drinking like an
average three bottles a day those
bottles for a for the consumption of a
whole year is produced within 80 seconds
so less than two minutes it's like it's
really really fast and the third thing
is like my most preferred industry it's
the brewing industry and so well I'm
Bavarian so we have a lot of breweries
and we make machines that the yeast
feels really perfectly and produces the
best beer ever but those are just like
three machines were producing we're also
like washing bottles labeling them and
all the different kinds
pecking them six-packs trays whatever
all the different kinds of machines and
putting it on pellets and also we have
like storages that means we have a lot
of different machines and the best thing
is like every the machine is different
for every client depending on the
product there are different specifics
though so there are none there are no
two machines which are the same in the
home world which is really cool but I'm
a data scientist I want to have like
sanitized data and whatever and that's
like no it doesn't exist every machine
is different and additionally it's that
our mechanical machines so there are
mechanical modifications on a daily
basis and once a year or every other
year there's an overhaul
that means you deconstruct the whole
machine change the wear parts and
reconstruct it reassemble it so you have
a new machine afterwards again and the
third thing is we are not running the
machines we're selling the machines so
we have pretty much no data about error
cases and the documentation in our
factories are rather bad sometimes they
write down something with paper and pen
if we're lucky but it's not the best
situation for us so how can we still
give like help the maintenance people to
do their job better so and they're the
big topic is a normal section because
that works also if you don't have much
information about the machines so what
is an old detection like a normal
section has a lot of different names
depending on the field so it can be like
outlier detection novelty detection
deviation detection exception mining
change deviation change detection so
there are a lot of different names
depending on in which field you are
it's called differently and the most
common explanation is and normally is an
observation which deviates so much from
other the observations is to arouse
suspicious that it was generated by a
different mechanism
so the data point is different than
everything else and what I personally
think is really important from a sling
normally may or may not be harmful and
not an anomaly is neutral it's nothing
bad it's nothing good it's neutral in
first place so now I have like like some
data for you it's like really not very
realistic apartment price to distance to
City Year so apparently there are just
two quarters in that city it's just a
really weird City but it's just to
explain what anomalies are like so what
are anomalies in first case you would
say like c1 and c2 that are the normal
states and like x1 and x2 are very
clearly anomalies and those are the
those are point anomalies that means one
measurement is so different that you say
that's definitely an anomaly then the
second batch which you would probably
recognize as anomaly is this that means
it's an collective anomaly every point
itself is normal but as there are like
50 different apartments with exactly the
same distance in the same price it's
weird there's something wrong that's
also an anomaly for c3 and x3 those
depending on you need some knowledge
about the city if a city has a third
quarter which is c3 or a road which is
lying more outside for x3 then those are
not anomalies if there's nothing like
that
there are also anomalies and actually
there's one more uh normally hidden in
there and that's like a contextual
anomaly mmm there's one apartment but
just just five square meters big that's
really weird you wouldn't pay so much
for it so it's important that you always
consider also the context of it summing
it up like there are different kinds of
anomalies say if it's a normal dip
stroke depends strongly on the goal and
it's often not completely clear like
those two and for the algorithms all the
algorithms are based on point anomalies
that means you have to transform the all
the different kinds of anomalies to
point anomalies so either with taking
the context into account or doing some
feature engineering these are the
different kinds of anomalies now which
different setups of a normal attention
are there it's like in machine learning
in the normal machine learning there are
three different kinds supervised simi
supervised and unsupervised supervised
means you have you have data and there
are error cases in and they are labeled
as error cases that means you can use
the normal machine learning methods you
just have to be careful about the
unbalanced classes because you have a
lot of healthy data so the machine is
operating normally and if just very very
little error cases the second part is
semi-supervised a normal tection that
means you have data and you know there
is no error case in all the data is
healthy so you know what the healthy
state looks like the third thing is
unsupervised that means you don't know
anything there could be errors in there
could be not you don't know now if like
a one practical example with you for you
and we will then go through the
different steps and look at the
algorithms and see what it means for
this example it's a filler so you can
see you like there are the bottles
coming in it's a beer filler bottles are
coming in being filled
but like coming out filled and then
being closed so that's a normal setup
for us and there are like motors which
drive this big carousel there so there's
one model with a gear and the only
measures we have are like for example
the temperature and the current of this
one motor what could happen here what
could go wrong in terms of maintenance
so like bearings could break of the
motor gears whirring out something
breaks in the machine or it get smaller
chested but the machine is still running
the machine is is running high speed
because it has to produce
and the only thing how you can detect
that there's something wrong is bhaiyya
by measuring the current or temperature
then like two questions which always
help me like which external influences
do we have here
the first those are like for at first
like the speed if the machine is
standing you would expect a different
current than when it's running full
speed that's pretty clear and the other
thing is like the product if you're
filling a 500 milliliter bottle or a 2
liter bottle it should be different so
you always have to take the product into
account those are like two contexts
which have to it has to be added to the
feature vector and the other question is
like which kind of a normal is to you
want to detect what things appear and
what are the people actually interested
in on-site and what happens here is like
we have some error cases which are like
progressive changes that means they're
slowly getting worse so the one bearing
after the other is breaking part by part
and so it's like a progressive change it
can be that the average is going up also
the amplitude or whatever pattern
appears more often and there are some
persistent changes so something breaks
and it doesn't repair itself it just
stays broken until it gets repaired that
means a pattern appears which is like
steps a stepwise over time the third
thing is like there are spikes too in
the data but in this case those don't in
there are no indication of an arrow
because that are just when you look at
the physical like electricity they peak
because of induction
that's nothing hit that doesn't have
anything to do with error cases it's
just like the physical properties of the
system when you have that you have to
think about okay I I'm interested in
those two but not in this so you need to
do some feature engineering and this is
actually the most important part of the
analysis it's like in machine learning
also for a normal text
this is really essential but I won't go
into detail because there will be like
two more talks after the lunch break so
if you're more interested in going those
ones but I very briefly like either you
use a lot of knowledge intuition
literature or they're also like packages
now like the most the biggest one is the
HTC SA with more than 7,000 features
implemented so you can just throw those
on the data for a normal section I
wouldn't recommend it to you I would
more take like for example the catch 22
package which reduces those 7,000
features to or the most 22 essential
ones to remove duplicates or if you're
interested in a native Python code that
would be like to use fresh for example
what does it mean for us like we would
either either use like some intuitive
measures here like median because we
don't want to have the peaks or like the
99 percentile or measures like that or
we would use the catch-22 because with
22 dimension it still works pretty good
for 7000 probably not then let's have a
look on unsupervised an older section so
the basic principle of unsupervised an
old erection is the maturity is normal
and the minority is unknown is an
anomaly that means if you look at the
densities here like all the green dots
where the density is high are normal so
the machine is operating like it should
and the red points are always what are
the typical ways how to calculate it it
would be like nearest neighbor measures
or density measures as you can see here
or you would do some clustering and then
you find like K different clusters and
then for every class that you look how
big is the cluster and depending on how
big and how dense the cluster is you
would say oh this clusters and normally
or not
and in general the tricky part of it is
always like setting the K setting all
the different parameters because it the
result strongly depends on it for our
case this is actually not very helpful
because we have an error cases of
persistent changes so the machine is
changing the state but it's not a
healthy state so it would just like to
jump from this cluster and to that
cluster so at the beginning its perp
still and normal in over time the normal
state gets an anomaly because it's rare
and the and the wrong has non healthy
state gets more and more normal so
that's actually nothing really helpful
for this kind of maintenance tasks so
we'll go on with C my supervisor normal
tension there you have you know what the
healthy state looks like and the very
basic principle is like you calculate
the distance to the healthy state this
can be made with like really distances
like the Mahalo Mahalo nobis distance
when you're like in an n-dimensional
space this would this takes the
covariance matrix into account or you
can model the the surface of this
n-dimensional healthy state like for
example with a one class support vector
machine so you have this super complex
and dimensional surface you model that
one and as soon as you're out of that
surface it would be an anomaly
the further away the more secure it's an
anomaly in the third thing which is the
perhaps bit surprising for some of you
it's like using principal component
analysis this is also an anomaly measure
because what are you doing you're having
the HealthEast data you find new basis
functions and then you throw away some
of the new basis functions and you have
a very specific reconstruction error
what happens if an anomaly comes in
which is actually represented by the
thrown away basis functions the
reconstruction grows reconstruction
error grows
so depending on which basic functions
you throw away this is also a way to
detect anomalies so that's actually
really really important
do not use any dimensional reduction
before an election the chance that he
would just throw away all the normals is
high so be careful with that so what is
happening with our example here it works
actually pretty good because you just
defined the starting point with an
expert as healthy and whenever it
changes no matter if it changes like
rapidly or slowly you will detect that
it goes away and that this is like an
anomaly and even the nicest thing here
is like if you have a new client if in a
new machine or over after an overhaul
you could just define the healthy state
again new and so you can retrain it
really fast but the tricky thing is like
it strongly strongly depends on the
training data if you don't have the
healthy state at the beginning the model
bully show will show you something but
it doesn't have to be make sense and
this is also the very tricky part
because we have some cases when for
example the motor is changed it's normal
that the motor at the moment has to work
harder until the looper vacation in such
works is like you it's like the same
everywhere so at the beginning actually
the current is higher and then over time
it the case to the normal state and so
it's really really it's the tricky part
to define at the right time point but
the right experts this healthy state but
in general it works really good and we
also have it in production in our system
in our client systems then but that
thing is like about how to set it
productive we have the thing that our
clients as where the world leader our
clients are like this to be
it all over the world and so internet
connection is there but it doesn't have
to be too stable and so what are we
doing we're calculating everything on
that device so we're we're having an
inch device in epoch at the client doing
all the calculation there and just if
there's an error this little information
this goes into the cloud that's not a
problem
and then we inform the people on site
for that and if there is a stable
internet connection you can just send
the beta as a bad shop into the cloud
because for us it's important to inform
the onset people in real time and not
like 24 hours later and what supports us
is like we're using like the AWS green
cross device which is it's really
comfortable for data scientists to use
because you can just package your Python
code so with all the different libraries
you need and send it to the to the edge
device it's just one button you have to
press and then it's on that device and
also like your safe your model as a
resource problem device and that's it
and afterwards to subscribe it through
the mqtt topic for sure for the theta
engineers like for the engineers who are
making it the system like super stable
and like multi-tenant and whatever it's
AWS is supporting a lot but it's still a
lot of work and for those who perhaps
have already worked with AWS h maker the
models which are already pre implemented
in sage maker cannot be deployed on edge
device yet but AWS is like publishing a
new service like every other week or
every other month so they will probably
fix that also soon so now that is let's
summarize what I've covered the last
minutes so anomalies may or may not be
harmful they are completely neutral and
that's also important too
talk to the like to tell the users if an
anomaly is thrown check the machine but
it's not does not have it I can have
different influences it can be that they
just did some maintenance or it could be
that something is broken then uh
normally depends a lot on it then the
normal interpretation depends a lot on
the context is it a spike is that a
progressive change what do you want to
see if you're looking for spikes then
look for spikes if you are not
interested in spikes then just ignore
them and for a future extraction my
question which are helping me is like
which external influences do you have
and which kind of events should be
detected and for the choice of algorithm
the most important question is like
which setup do you have do you have some
labels do you know what the healthy
state is like or do you know if it or
don't you know anything about it then
you have to go with unsupervised and for
the model deployment it's also important
to know like when is then form
information yet does it have to be in
real time or is it okay to get the
information like 24 hours later so
thanks a lot for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much for that do we have
questions from anyone oh we have lots of
questions
meetings we have lots of questions or
should we start
you are the nearest so thank you for an
thank you for for the presentation my
interest is regarding reporting back for
the in on shop floor engineers so you
detected something you found that some
animality is throw the algorithm and now
it's to tell them back what is the root
cause of this anomaly how did you
communicate it back I mean what type of
algorithms did support you in order to
communicate it in a clear way it doesn't
help to tell them okay something is
going bad and then they just start
hunting it's because the rest right now
I'm having the same problem right now so
how to communicate it did you have an
experience on that direction and my
second question is that how did you
communicate so I played with GIS fresh
and algorithms when you combine you have
multiple sensor so it's not one but
maybe up to hundreds how do you compile
and and all those combined to a single
incident if it is okay or not that tells
you if it exists or not
so how did you combine or go around this
issue you have energy speed you have all
these actually those two questions are
like combined for me and because what we
usually do is like we combine the data
of one part of the of the machine
so if we have like of this one more we
have the current the temperature and
whatever so we have just those
information in the model and so if I
want to tell the operator that something
is going weird I already tell him like
Oh
this part is going weird so this already
helps in the communication because it's
like you don't say Oh something in the
filler is wrong because that's not
really helpful for the operators that
they are like yeah thanks but you can
already say like Oh in this part of the
machine something is weird
so please check this in the next
maintenance window and this also helps
like for the models because it reduces
the amount of features on the amount of
incoming data a lot because like in my
case there are not like 1000 sensors in
which describe one part of the machine
but it's like maximum like five or such
and so it's like really reduced because
you want to get give the detail
information to the client so these
sensors are some extent extremely
correlated so energy is correlated with
if there are some strongly correlated
ones which was like we we take the the
one where we expect the most input like
with also with discussing with the
mechanical engineers but it's just like
they are not that made that many
different so it's it works pretty good
actually
[Music]
thank you yeah I found it a very
interesting talk but I had a question
about particularly the feature
extraction so you're using four models
mostly I think SVM's and if I understand
if I understood correctly neural Nets
but for these models and especially for
the future extraction you're a priori
assuming a distribution for your data
for example if I take the logarithm
of my data set let's just say I have one
feature yeah it's a log
I'm penalizing everything that's very
close to zero so this will totally skew
my metro and that depends on the metric
too but let's just say we're taking l2
so it seems to me that for the forget
the models to the future extraction
we're a priori assuming a distribution
so my question is fir your modeling are
you when you're looking at the data that
is good data in some sense like you have
no anomalies are you computing the
distribution in some way from that and
then using that to tune your nearest
neighbors model because that also has an
a priori assumption on the on the
underlying distribution of your data
yeah it always depends on like I said
Farah mainly worked with more the soup
as massima supervised machine learning
methods and there you can for example
used like and just go back to the slide
and like a one plus support vector
machine and then it's already like model
tuna like you have already the
distributions represented in the space
because you're having the n dimensional
surface and so it's already included in
the model you know so for you mean for
the SVM specific specifically for the
it's the specific kind of like one
classes of M yeah and what's your metric
that you're using again for the for the
SI I'm just l to essentially or using
because you're saying you're using mono
base distance and that's essentially
radial it's essentially so it's computed
from no more at normality assumption of
normality yeah so that's our that seems
sorry yeah sure like my Lenovo's
distances like more on calculating the
Gaussian distribution yes and yeah
actually our data is mainly distributed
ocean okay that's what I was yeah
normality exactly thank you
okay more questions people yep
thank you that was very interesting
thank you very much actually also worked
for a long time in a company for I know
my section of Time series and I think I
was dealing with the same problems what
I wanted to know he didn't talk at all
about your data I wanted to know what
kind of time series they were like for
example how the sensors were like
measuring how often and yet just wanted
to know that I'm sure like we're mainly
using the sensors which are already
implement like already built into the
machine because every sensor we have to
add additionally it's just it's too
expensive in the end for the client so
our data is coming over the PLC so we're
like restricted to a resolutions of like
maximum 100 milliseconds so it's like
current data and like all that are all
physical measures and they usually
depending on it depending on which kind
of measure it is like with the
resolution of like 100 milliseconds or
like up to one second because
temperature is not changing that fast
okay at least one more question maybe
thank you very much again for the for a
nice talk I have one question about the
about the training of your models so
what I'm interested in is that so you do
you have you see in any of the of the
physical quantities that your your
sensors are measuring any sort of
consistent drift and how your models are
coping with that with the drift I mean
do you retrain your model to detect
anomalies with respect to this drift and
then if you retrain your model then how
they cope with the wear with the
parameters that are actually are
drifting we usually don't have any like
every drift means that the system is
changing and every change of the system
is interesting for us so when we have
drifts that are actually things we want
to detect
[Music]
you're definitely right there are like
also changes over the course of the year
like depending on the temperature in the
whole stuff is changing our time but
we're collecting like we're trying out
at the moment how big the influence
actually is because in terms of a motor
which is has a temperature usually of
about eighty degrees it doesn't matter
that much if it has like 15 degrees or
20 degrees at all it's not that
dependent on it thank you let me get one
more question
oops but before I said someone just
asked me about slides I don't know what
this if there's a standard policy here
but at the very least you can ask Andre
oh and I'm sure she'll be happy to send
them to you
same goes for me in the next talk okay
my question is about the sensors you're
using for evaluating and you said you're
using what you have and did you think
about analyzing sound for example you
can take your mobile phone and record
the machine and a broken car has a very
everybody can hear something is broken
and you can you tell about something
about what kind of data would is good
for this kind of detection and what is
more complicated it's actually a very
good question because we are already
thought about this too because like what
happens for maintenance people
maintenance stuff in the in the factory
the most experienced ones are just
sitting on their stair on the chair just
listening and then just telling the new
people like oh go to this machine this
and that is broken so it's like the
people on site really hear a lot of
stuff so we already thought about doing
that the biggest problem is to have a
mind like it's pretty expensive to have
a microphone which can go into the
factory because it has to fulfill a lot
of requirements and so we if we're
planning to try it out but we didn't try
it out but I would be interested in your
experience so we could discuss it
afterwards though that will have to be
discussion afterwards because we we got
move on we've got a like 90 seconds to
set up for the next talk so
[Applause]